[Music]
on this Tuesday night Ontario's plan to
ban a strike by school workers the
controversial strategy we're making sure
that the students stay in class and why
critics say it goes too far a horrific
cycle of domestic abuse we wouldn't stop
punching me the former partner of a
Saskatchewan mass murderer talks about
Despair and hope a global news exclusive
death threats against the Deputy Prime
Minister Christian Freeland will get a
Bullet to the Head New Evidence as
Convoy organizers testify in Ottawa plus
the burden and sometimes when I think
about it I feel like I'm back in shock
and the honor of being this year's
Silver Cross mother
foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin in Ontario tonight on a heated
labor dispute that could affect tens of
thousands of students and families the
Ontario government has introduced
legislation to ban a plan strike by 55
000 education workers and impose a
contract on them and it intends to use a
heavy Hammer to do it the
notwithstanding Clause of the Charter of
Rights and Freedoms section 33 of the
Canadian Charter is known as the
notwithstanding Clause that gives
Parliament or the legislature of a
province the ability to expressly
declare through the passage of a law a
mechanism to override certain portions
of the charter for five years
the idea behind the Clause is to give
elected lawmakers control over important
issues and prevent unelected judges from
having too much power Ontario Premier
Doug Ford wants to use it to stop
education workers including Librarians
custodians and early childhood Educators
from walking out on Friday critics say
that is a serious overreach Global
Toronto's Queens Park bureau chief Colin
Demello is with me Colin hi there why
not stick to the bargaining table why is
Premier Ford threatening to do this
yeah the simple answer Donna is uh
precedence the former liberal government
here in Ontario about 10 years ago had
done the same thing they implemented
legislation that imposed a contract on
teachers unions and took away their
right to strike those unions took the
government to court and a judge later
determined that their you their Charter
rights were infringed upon they later
award those unions hundreds of millions
of dollars in fees in a settlement the
Ford government wants to avoid that
outcome by using the notwithstanding
Clause to Shield the government the
premier and cabinet ministers from any
impending legal action from this Union
the premier contends that this is all
about keeping schools open after two
years of closures due to covid-19 we're
making sure that the students stay in
class I'm going to repeat that they're
going to stay in class
we want parents to know that we're doing
everything we can to make sure students
don't miss one single day in class
now the use of the notwithstanding
clause in this context is particularly
controversial it's raised a lot of
questions not just from the premier's
political critics here at Queen's Park
in Toronto but also from the highest
levels of government from prime minister
Justin Trudeau
using the notwithstanding Clause to
suspend workers rights is wrong I know
that that collective bargaining
negotiations are sometimes difficult but
it has to happen
and now the federal Justice Minister
David lametti is musing about
potentially taking the Ontario
government to court over its use of the
notwithstanding Clause although they
weren't so sure about exactly what they
were going to do just yet Colin the
strike is set to start on Friday what
should parents and students make of all
this and plan for
well here's the thing Kewpie and the
government are on a collision course on
Friday QP says it will be going on
strike 55 000 education support workers
school boards have already announced
that some schools in this province will
be shutting down there is a chance just
a slight chance that the two sides could
come together with mediation over the
next couple of days and hammer out a
contract if that doesn't happen the
government will go ahead with this
legislation QP will go ahead with its
strike and 2 million students will find
themselves once again sitting at home
all right Colin Demello in Toronto
tonight thanks
lawyers for Premier Doug Ford and his
former solicitor general Sylvia Jones
were in court today trying to keep them
from testifying at the inquiry into the
federal emergencies act last week Ford
and Jones were summoned to appear at the
inquiry but are arguing they have
parliamentary privilege which provides
immunity to sitting politicians their
lawyers say there would be irreparable
harm to the rule of law if that
privilege was ignored the inquiry
commissioner argues Ford and Jones have
overstated their privilege and their
application should be dismissed today
the inquiry into the use of the
emergencies act heard about a death
threat to Deputy Prime Minister
Christian Freeland made back in February
when protesters occupied the streets
near Parliament Hill for weeks
testifying today was one of the Convoy
organizers who says he wanted the whole
thing to be peaceful government lawyers
argue organizers were openly Fanning the
Flames of anger and in some cases making
serious threats David Aiken reports
I've been speaking with the guys a lot
of them were able to get turned around
trucker Chris Barber had just one motive
to help organize the freedom Convoy that
would paralyze Ottawa for me personally
it was the Border amenities Barber led
the Western Convoy from Alberta but when
he arrived in the nation's capital he
found disorganization and Chaos not just
among ottawa's police force but also
among several different protest groups
that had already arrived nobody knew
where to go nobody had Direction on his
social media accounts Barber repeatedly
insisted that Convoy participants abide
by a code of ethics this Convoy to
Ottawa next week on Sunday
is a peaceful protest
but some did not get that message Judo
someone's gonna make you catch a bullet
one day that was Pat King another Convoy
leader who will testify later this week
that video was entered as evidence today
by government of Canada lawyers trying
to show there was good reason to invoke
the emergencies act and those lawyers
had more the opp apprehended someone
in Ottawa
who was wearing body armor
and carrying a large knife
along with other knives a sword and
machetes that were seized out of his
truck I was not aware of that barber
also did not know about a death threat
emailed to the Deputy Prime Minister
Christia Freeland will get a Bullet to
the Head
prepare to feel our wrath the last thing
I ever wanted was a letter like that I
never ever heard that story up until now
the last question then is would you
agree with me that when when you start a
fire and fan the flames
it can get out of control Barber did
agree with that but he's also one of
several Convoy leaders testifying this
week that are also facing criminal
charges for their activities here in
Ottawa last February David Aiken Global
News
Ottawa
in Saskatchewan there is still years of
healing to do after the mass stabbing on
the James Smith Cree Nation nearly two
months ago miles Sanderson went on an
early morning Killing Spree when it was
over 11 people were dead including his
own brother now in a global news
exclusive his longtime partner is
speaking out Vanessa Burns opens up
about the hours and days leading up to
the attacks and the years of domestic
abuse she suffered Nathaniel Dove
reports in a warning his story contains
graphic details of domestic abuse that
are difficult to listen to
and then he's like oh you want to fight
and then he starts punching me he
wouldn't stop punching me for years
Vanessa Burns had suffered the father of
her children controlling paranoid and
vicious she says beating her again and
again we got on top of me because
this time would be the last but only
because it was the Prelude to even more
violence miles Sanderson committed all
of the homicides alone on September 4th
miles Sanderson went on a stabbing spree
injuring 18 people and killing 11. among
the injured Vanessa's mother Joyce miles
stabbed her and twisted the knife among
the dead Vanessa's father Earl my dad
wasn't going to go get help or anything
he chased miles he wasn't scared about
speaking to Global's Ashley Stewart
Vanessa says Earl hated Miles because of
how he treated her and her journals also
shared with Stuart show the aching
loneliness and confusion Vanessa lived
am I that desperate to be loved to think
I can change someone she writes deep
inside I hold such pain she had left
Sanderson many times but she always took
him back he preyed on her compassion for
their five children when he showed up
again before the September long weekend
he asked for her help to sell drugs
Vanessa drove him around
she left James Smith after he hit her
again she wasn't there when he went on
his violent spree in the months since
his last release she says he had been
diagnosed as bipolar she also thought he
might be schizophrenic he was talking a
little crazy during those times you're
hanging out like well I'm just gonna go
back to the city and kill myself I'm
gonna go buy a fentanyl pill I'll kill
myself Sanderson died in RCMP custody
shortly after his arrest sources tell
global news from a fatal overdose
free from the threat Vanessa says she's
focusing on taking care of her family
she went to a shelter after the last
time miles attacked her parents now she
wants to work in one to help women like
her Nathaniel Dove Global News Saskatoon
if you or someone you know has been a
victim of intimate partner violence you
can call the Canadian Resource Center
for victims of crime the numbers
1-877-232-2610
coming up the debate over whether the
U.S should support Ukraine Battleground
Ohio
[Music]
one week to go until midterm elections
in the U.S and the races are getting
tighter in several States tonight we're
looking at Ohio and the contest for
Senate between Republican JD Vance and
Democrat Tim Ryan Vance is a newcomer to
the political scene but he's well known
for his best-selling book hillbilly
elegy that was adapted into a Netflix
special Democrat Tim Ryan is relying on
his experience as a career politician to
try to sway votes and in one small town
outside Cleveland voters have just one
thing on their mind the war in Ukraine
our Jeff Semple is there
anything else that you still have an
idea this butcher shop offers A Taste of
Ukraine yes
just meat now
4 800 miles from Keith
this is Ukrainian Village in Ohio home
to the state's largest
ukrainian-american community Luba
molokovski's sister lives in Ukraine
with a newborn
their neighborhood recently hit by a
Russian rocket I'm feeling so bad and
that's so dangerous but what we can do I
don't know one thing she will do is vote
in the upcoming midterm elections
Ohio's Republican senate seat is up for
grabs it's one of a handful of states
that could determine the balance of
power in Washington
opinion polls suggest that the race for
Ohio's all-important senate seat is too
close to call and among the deeply
divisive issues dominating this campaign
is America's ongoing financial support
for Ukraine let's talk about the stakes
of this election Ohio's Republican
candidate has said the U.S should stop
spending tax dollars supporting Ukraine
I gotta be honest with you I don't
really care what happens to you praying
one way or another I wanted to ask about
your position on America's continued
support for Ukraine we asked JD Vance to
clarify his stance look I don't think
that we can continue funding the
Ukrainian War indefinitely I would like
us to de-escalate and spend American
dollars on American priorities that
position is backed by a growing number
of Republican lawmakers I think if the
Republicans take control of congresses
it looks like they will I see very
little likelihood of funding continuing
at least at the level that it has the
Democrats meanwhile are pushing for
another Aid package for Ukraine this is
700 some pages this retired journalist
is documenting America's Ukrainian
population 45 000 ukrainians live in
Ohio alone
many including himself are long-time
Republicans now preparing to vote
Democrat they never voted for Democrats
but the the they see that they must in
this case because Ukraine's very
survival is at stake we've had
tremendous support a group representing
Ohio's ukrainians believes members of
the state's large Eastern European
diaspora will also be voting Democrat
the Baltic Republic's estonians latvians
the lithuanians with the polls the
Jewish Community there's a force
multiplier so we have many many allies
in the community I mean let's face it
Ukraine is fighting on because the
Western World Is providing the aid in
economic support and the future of U.S
support for Ukraine could hinge on this
election result Jeff Semple Global News
Parma Ohio
Brazil's outgoing president jair
bolsonaro has spoken he didn't concede
losing the election in that country but
he did signal he'll cooperate with the
transfer of power bolsonaro lost the
election to Luis Ignacio Lula de Silva
two days ago and has been silenced since
then today he didn't acknowledge the
results but he did say he'd follow the
rules of Brazil's Constitution his chief
of staff told reporters he's been
authorized to begin the transition
process
penny pinching and thinning wallets
ahead why Canadians feel they're on
shaky economic ground
[Music]
we know many people are struggling to
keep up with their bills and are racking
up debt well now we have a snapshot of
how inflation and Rising interest rates
are adding up Equifax Canada says the
nation's average credit card balance has
hit a record high of more than twenty
one hundred dollars and new polling
conducted exclusively for Global News
suggests an increasing number of
Canadians feel like they are on the
brink and gaviola looks at who is most
worried and why
even though inflation is starting to
ease we're squeezed at the pumps and at
the grocery store you're wondering when
does it stop because before you know
like prices I knew only went up every so
often but like I'm telling you I'm
seeing this thing every week every week
I can't budget people feel financially
beat up 84 of Canadians are concerned
inflation will make everyday purchases
less affordable according to exclusive
ipsos polling for Global News one in
five say they're completely out of money
and there's no way they can handle a
price increase for Necessities Canadians
are concerned about being able to afford
the basic necessities of life but
they're also concerned about the
holidays and whether or not they're
going to be able to buy gifts for their
family their children and their and
their friends women people between the
ages of 18 and 34 and households with
children are most likely to be concerned
about their finances parents are the
most concerned out of all the
demographic groups that we've studied
they've got more Mouse to feed they've
got more backs to clothe and they're
feeling the pinch more than others
they're worried about being able to put
food on the table 84 believe Canada
could see a recession in 2023 and
despite the tight labor market and
worker shortage one in three are worried
they could lose their job if the economy
doesn't improve and if we just look back
to the recession they have good reason
to be worried younger people women more
likely to work in a service industry for
example were more likely to lose their
jobs and be laid off in in 2020 so
they've got very recent memory of
economic hardship they work in the
service industry and my work is impacted
on you know the being I need the place
to be open to make money if anything it
might help me actually because then I'll
be able to afford stuff you know like uh
if there was a recession and prices went
down
then I could maybe afford a house in the
future we'll see the hope is this
Collective financial hardship will
improve affordability in the long run
but right now it's clear Canadians are
feeling the hurt and gaviola Global News
Toronto
the federal government is planning to
increase immigration levels over the
next few years last year 405 000
immigrants came to the country today the
immigration Minister announced new
targets the plan is to accept 465
000 new arrivals next year increasing to
half a million in 2025. the minister
says it's necessary to help solve the
country's labor shortage
next this year's Silver Cross mother
tells me about her son and the heavy
burden she is honored to bear this
Remembrance Day
[Music]
everyone has their own way of
remembering those who have been lost in
war and conflict and every Remembrance
Day one mother is awarded the Silver
Cross it is a heavy burden she
represents all the mothers and families
whose children went off on a Canadian
military Mission and never came home
this year it's candy Gruff from Lacombe
Alberta her son Master Corporal Byron
gref was the last Canadian Soldier to
die in Afghanistan
he wore his Canadian military uniform
with such Pride his mother candy tells
me now it's one of the few tangible ways
she has left to remember her son Byron I
want to
hold my head up high Walk Tall because
that's what Byron would do and that's
what he would want me to do
mom be proud and I am he was her eldest
child good at hockey mischievous and
goal-oriented he was determined and
funny we all missed that laugh
as a teenager Byron signed up for Cadets
though the family had no history of
serving in the military and then Along
Came grade 12 and he said I would like
to join the military but did you think
immediately that might mean he would be
deployed
at some stage it did cross my mind it
did
and then I just
trusted that the military
would train him and they did they
trained him very well
its first mission to Afghanistan was in
2007. it was a dangerous time oh my
goodness yes
the phone would ring
or I would see the news and I would see
something had had happened
and your stomach just turns
and you think please please
Byron made it home from that mission by
then he was a dad he doted on his young
son Keller got married to the boy's
mother Lindsay and in October of 2011
made sure he was home for the birth of
their daughter Brielle
this is the only photo they have of the
three of them
two weeks later what Byron's mother
feared happened now heavy black smoke
could be seen from most of the city the
armored NATO bus he was on was hit by a
suicide Car Bomb packed with 700 kilos
of explosives he was one of 17 people
killed he wasn't even in active combat
then he was training Afghan soldiers
that whole period must be a blur it is I
think a person stays in shock and
sometimes when I think about it I feel
like I'm back in shock again
[Music]
foreign
years have passed since his casket came
home Byron is now buried in the cemetery
in the town where he grew up near a
memorial to all the 158 Canadian
soldiers who died in Afghanistan
her son the last one killed the final
inscription they're all so important
each and every one of them
I believe there's a bond between all of
the Silver Cross families
I want to do him proud
and
represent people as they should be
for all the pain that connects us
and Candy Graff this year's Silver Cross
mother will be in Ottawa for Remembrance
Day we will have live coverage of that
ceremony starting at 10 30 a.m Eastern 7
30 Pacific right here on global and at
globalnews.ca
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is the village of Kimberly Ontario near
Lake Huron we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to us and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you